this is a Fox News Alert the Attorney
General says there will be no second
special counsel for now Jeff Sessions is
rejecting a Republican request for a
special prosecutor to look into alleged
bias at the Justice Department and the
FBI but he is authorizing an
investigation and leaving the door open
for more possible action later chief
national correspondent ed Henry is here
with the breaking details
Brett this could be a big deal because
what the Attorney General is really
saying is he may not need a second
special counsel just yet to find out
whether FBI and Justice Department
officials during the Obama years broke
laws when they engaged in FISA abuse to
spy on the Trump campaign because he
already has a criminal prosecutor
prosecutor all over it sessions
revealing for the first time he already
has been quietly having US attorney John
Huber of Utah operating of course
outside of the Beltway using his
prosecutorial powers with a broad
mandate to investigate misconduct that
could extend beyond FISA abuse so former
FBI officials James Comey Andrew McCabe
could be facing scrutiny for not just
failing to tell the FISA judge that the
anti-trump dossier was paid for by the
DNC and the Clinton campaign this
prosecutor could be looking at McCabe's
leaking his lying to investigators plus
those FBI text messages sessoms writing
quote I am confident mr. Hoover's review
will include a full complete and
objective evaluation of these matters in
a manner that is consistent with the law
and the facts I receive regular updates
from mr. Huber and upon the conclusion
of his review would receive his
recommendations as to whether any
matters not currently under
investigation should be opened whether
any matters currently under
investigation require further resources
or whether any matters merit the
appointment of a special counsel now
sessions faced heat again last night
when his revealed the Justice Department
Inspector General was reviewing this and
critics said that that official there
does not have prosecutorial powers well
John Huber does and remember sessions
hinted at this without naming humor you
were in a recent interview with shannon
bream watch i have appointed a person
outside of washington many years in
Department of Justice to look at all the
allegations that the House Judiciary
Committee
members sent to us and we're conducting
that investigation now Hubert was first
nominated by then President Barack Obama
so if he brings criminal charges it will
have credibility
likewise if he finds no criminal
wrongdoing it'll be noted this was
someone who was renown ated by President
Trump with the backing we should note of
conservative Republican Utah senator
Michael E Brett all right we'll follow
this one ed thank you